- Imagine athletes stopping every time
they heard people booing them
or talking shit while
they were on the court.
That's how I think about
being an entrepreneur.
Like, of course, or just living life.
Just imagine that.
You're on the free-throw
line and somebody like,
they just, they cry or
they don't take the shot.
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
♪ I move with the weight
of the world on my neck ♪
♪ Can't lie I been stressed
but it's all on me ♪
♪ Need a verse, need
advice, nigga call on me ♪
♪ Everybody got drive til the car on E ♪
♪ Gotta broad on E and she
all on me, put the jaws on ♪
- First in line what's up?
Teaming up with Chase a huge
client of mine at Vayner Media.
I'm sending you, because
I trust you the most,
this little survey.
We got some surprises for you.
We need your two cents on
your thoughts about where the
content can go in an SMB
entrepreneurial environment.
Really appreciate it and am excited
for some of you to be excited as well.
- [Camera man] And then the
other one is for 1:37 PM.
- [Gary] In their story, or?
- [Cameraman] Yeah, in
their story, so vertical.
- What's up guys it's Gary V, so fired up.
1:37 PM is finally live, the
dot com experience is here.
Swipe up, get on it, bookmark it,
sign up, own it, feel
it, live it, let's go.
♪ Budget no time for judgin',
I'm for sure that I want it ♪
♪ Won't settle, pedal
past opponents, I'm ♪
♪ Half my niggas trappin' corners ♪
♪ Other half back and forth with ♪
♪ Public housin', unemployment ♪
♪ We just searchin' for enjoyment ♪
- Instagram live, what up?
It is now the Tuesday after Labor Day.
Officially shit is real.
It's super clunky for me, to get
for me, a true lover of work,
even for me the first day back
off of a extended layaway, is
kind of like blaargh you know?
- [Camera Man] And then
back on the channel
the first day after a while.
- Yeah.
But I need that first meeting.
I've never done the whole LA thing.
I need that first meeting.
- You might not even get back
into it until Thursday, really.
- No, no, I'll have one
here in a second, relax.
I just need to get goin'.
What's goin on--oh, if you're
in New York or New Jersey,
the Super Tasting, the
wine event, October 8th,
you should definitely
go to winelibrary.com,
click the banner at the
top, you'll be seeing a lot
from it tomorrow.
I'm excited about that, come
drink some wine with me,
that'll be fun.
Goin' to some meetings,
in my office out there,
that's what I'm doin'.
Tip of the day: stop fuckin' listening
to anybody but yourself.
Outside noises.
So many of them.
Imagine athletes stopping
every time they heard people
booing them or talking shit
while they were on the court.
That's how I think about
being an entrepreneur,
of course, or just living life.
Like just imagine that,
you're on the free-throw line
and somebody like, and they just cry
or they don't take the shot.
Alright, I need to go.
And that post I put in my stories
about Twitter is very real.
Just an incredible place for us to jam.
See ya.
I took a break, it was really good.
Really good time.
How have you been?
(indistinct conversation)
- [Female Office Admin] I have to check,
I will see if I can make it from
11:30 to 5:00, I think we
booked it from 12:00 to 5:00.
But, we could push it earlier.
- Yeah, I have an 11:40.
- [Female Office Admin]
You have an 11: 40?
Okay, alright I'll go check
and see if--
- Eddie!
(laughs)
- Lookin' good in your
photo yesterday, man.
- [Eddie] Thanks, man.
- I would try to double-tap
that a couple times.
- So everyone's already here.
- Hey, hey! Love it.
- Everyone's camped in all the rooms.
- That's so awesome.
(laughs)
How are ya?
Awesome.
- And then let me go check
and see if it's available now.
- Okay.
- And if I can get
you in there early.
- Okay, thank you.
What's up, guy.
- Hello!
- How are ya?
- Good.
(laughs)
- [Male Worker] I totally
just called for that.
- Totally fine.
- No worries.
- [Female Office Admin] Thanks so much!
Alright, I'll get a system here,
and I just want to verify--
- Hey guys.
Hey Jeff, hey Mickey.
How are ya, brother?
You guys are gettin'
into the real shit, huh?
(laughs)
Awesome.
Alright so, I'm just trying to get
my bearings from all this stuff.
Obviously, I'm just getting
the three of us aligned
on any conversations around
media within the office.
I think we're all talkin'
the same language,
I think the question becomes--
Let me throw out scenarios 'cause
this is a very tight-knit circle.
One of the ideas I have is
opening an office and it becoming
Vayner Media, and me and
Mickey doing something
more entrepreneurial, or
if Chuck or SMB, or things
of that nature, so I don't
wanna do anything too macro,
at the same token, if
Georgia Pacific comes in
and wants to do something meaningful,
or something else brews,
just want to get a sense
of getting the three of us
speaking the same language.
(slow melodic beats)
- [Female Office Admin]
Alright, Josh is here.
- Hey Josh!
- [Josh] How are ya?
- [Camera Man] How are you?
- Hey--
- My name's David.
- [Josh] Oh, David, nice to meet you.
- How are ya?
- Hey, brother.
- Real pleasure.
- Of course.
(rap music)
- Thank you, my man.
- Thank you.